representative Bickford would you please
go out and see if uh substitute
representative bogert is Handy please
thank you
okay the chair calls together the
executive session on um Senate Bill
574 an appointment of temporary agent
for minor child or incapacitated person
before we proceed we uh welcome
representative bogert as a seed
filler and you were from highways
and Public Works Public Works
wow well we're going to learn a lot
because we don't know anything about
that just
kids well I have I'm I'm happy to be
here because I'm going to learn about
kids good well we we should
enjoy that okay you've read the bill
looks to anybody have a any comments on
it before we entertain a
motion representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to let people know I did have a a
couple questions during the hearings um
and it was really because I had um
investigated um different a couple
different states and how they approached
this um but I feel satisfied um I went
back and researched a few more States
and um you know although there's you
know different wording and um the
structure is pretty much the same and it
seems like it works fine for the other
states um and there are me and it's true
that many many other states actually
have this in statute already so just
wanted
to you and I neglected to say to our
seat filler some committee chairs want
the seat fillers to keep your mouth shut
until you vote the way you're told I
value the input questions from people it
brings a bre to us so if you've got a
question put your hand up address me as
uh the all- wise one and then I will let
you go okay anyone
else chair will entertain a
motion now you can
speak remember you get to write a
wonderful report on this for the would
you like to do this yes thank you Mr
chairman
I'd like to um motion I'd like to move
the motion ought to pass
please any further
discussion yeah representative Bickford
would you uh rotate your name plate 180
degrees they know who you are I mostly
remember thank you okay
um thank you Mr chairman um I just I
missed this public hearing I was at the
Senate at the time um so I was hoping
that someone could give me a uh a
discussion about uh when this is
utilized like is it when maybe someone
goes into military service that sort of
thing uh and they I've seen that before
with two reservists Mom and Dad end up
having to sign the children over to
other
you would okay would
anybody have uh
Recollections from your notes oh let's
say representative Greg I bet would
thank you Mr chairman I was like yeah I
recall so the it's such that if let's
say you are going to go out of town
Let's do an easy one you're going to go
on vacation I'm going to go on vacation
I'm going to leave my dad with my
children well it's it's pretty customary
for a lot of people to get something
notorized saying that if you know my
child needs medical care or whatever
else that my dad is now in my stad going
to be able to direct care for my minor
children the however without a statute
like this particular statute on the
books it's not legally binding so we can
say that but in other states where I've
seen it before it's because there is an
RSA on the books that allows that to
happen we don't have anything legally
allowing that happen so a doctor could
deny Care Now is it likely we don't know
but we don't want to take that chance if
there's something uh crucial so that's
what it does um does that explain it uh
thank you um follow up followup uh I
thought I saw in here somewhere about
two notorized
signatures is did I or no two witnesses
I see it now no uh uh line 10
um is I don't know what your question is
sorry line 10 um oh about whether or not
you have two signatures
yeah so you need a notary
or doesn't
say
yeah I don't know if I
permission permission to representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for the question
representative Vick um so that I think
is in reference to um and we had um
talked about that in in hearing um Most
states um will create a a form you know
it's like a form that you follow and um
other states that I have researched do
have a form and they do have an area for
signatures that are not notorized
um and that's where that would um come
into play um
follow up on follow up follow up um
seems like two notaries seems like a lot
to me
and
um where would I get the for town hall
or
online maybe M Raymond would help me I
mean representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman So currently there is no form
in New Hampshire so we have to do the
bill first and then the form in
Massachusetts you could find it um like
if you Google it it'll come up and I
think it's in their um judiciary's
website but but I'm not sure um but it's
something that like you could download
this also opens the door to not needing
a form you could write your own you
could type up your own letter as a
parent as you can now um but it gives it
the statutory weight so in testimony um
someone came and talked about how um
they had sent their kids to I think 10
to the grandparents for this for some
time in the summer which was their
normal process and one of her kids got
an ear infection um and the doctor in
Tennessee didn't want to treat them
without something notorized inwriting
that cited a statute that gave Grandma
permission to seek it um in that
particular person's case she had a
military form because the military has
these for people um but New Hampshire
didn't have anything or any statutory
thing so her feeling was something like
this would allow for other families to
have that same advantage that the
military families have very good um so I
would hope that it would be someplace
like the traditional brand or I don't
know who else would would have these on
their websites yeah maybe city
hall
right I I didn't so they're suggesting
maybe pediatricians could have it on
their websites for parents um it
actually made me think cuz my my kids go
visit their grandparents in Maine every
summer um and they sometimes go to
Canada and we've only ever gotten like
we type something up we get it notorized
but it didn't occur to me that it
wouldn't cover them if they had a
non-emergency medical
issue okay thank you it was good
testimony yeah the motion before us is
ought to pass moved by representative
Nelson seconded by representative long
on Senate Bill 574 are we ready would
the clerk please call the role chairman
Pearson yes Vice chairman long yes
representative Damon yes representative
Bickford yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative bot yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative LC yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes
motion carries 13 to Z 13 to Z with
absences representative
Perez
missing
grossan
and
okay and representative Nelson will not
leave this ZIP code until the report is
done as aided by representative Greg and
anyone else who wants to jump in with
you okay good thank you that ends the
exec session at 574 now the fund starts
open the exec session on Senate Bill
5459 and uh before we um actually do
anything I have an amendment with me as
the prime sponsor representative long as
the
co-sponsor and I am passing them around
not Pearson and long but the the
amendment
papers and here's a couple extra in case
and the reason for the
amendment is very simply we as as I
emailed you we had a number of wonderful
bills come out of this committee
unanimously they went to the house floor
and all they needed was a Voice
vote then they went over to the Senate
where these bills were all put into
interim
study and by these bills I mean the ones
that are now being passed
around these are the bills that um came
out of here unanimously there three four
different bills
and in case you forgot
them here they are 185 475 618 and
1263 each of them has been put back to
back to back to back in the
amendment yesterday I went through and
did it side by sides to make sure what
amendment
1673 has is word for word
what the four amendments
are can you repeat those three those
four bills please I'm going to do better
than that I'm going to ask you to take
the amendment
1673 that you've just been handed take
that and a pen because I'm going to walk
you through which is what
okay I think that's one of
each okay
if you take uh the amendment
1673 please and put a line above 11
number 11 on the front page and put a
line under 19 on the front page and in
between all of that put HB
185 okay got
it that is
185 you've already got a line above 20
now put a line above
25 and put in the middle 475 House Bill
475 is lines 20 to 24 say the second one
line 20 to 24 is House Bill
475 now you've already got a line above
25 go to the next
page page two of the amendment and put a
line
above nine and everything between 25 on
the first
page and eight on the second page is
House Bill
618 word for
word and
then you've already got a
line over nine on page two put in 1263
that is the entire page two go over to
page three it is still
1263 and it goes down to put a line
under
22 so now you have four builds word for
word and in case my old eyes are not
working well we've got
um copies that have been sent
around now on page three lines 23 to the
end pick up what each one of those bills
above
has for effective dates and yes this
matches the original bills
exactly so therefore what you have in
front of you Amendment
1673 restores four house bills that came
out of this committee
unanimously went to the house floor
Voice vote and over the to the Senate
where they just yes representative Greg
um thank you Mr chairman and just uh one
note of Correction the first bill that
you have on here House Bill 185 uh did
not come out unanimously out of this
committee and I won't speak for anyone
else but I did not support that
approximately equal parenting time
I 11 to stand corrected thank you 11
thank you
you don't need to speak to that that was
B she worked on
it it was
won't this is
185 okay my uh Vice chair and I both
admit we thought we had done our
homework on this and obviously we
didn't uh we could pass the
Amendment with those lines
stricken do we have to go to OS to have
this done
first I saw in finance they did not do
it that way they said how many want to
pass this on the basis of these lines
taken
out all right will you
uh uh yeah get out run there right now
Pat and take out 11 to 19
okay uh well you could escort
him we
did yeah go ahead yeah
way I didn't get all the bills did you
get them all you
didn't well these are in
this they're supposed to be but I don't
see they're not that's why I was
know because this
is 1269 yeah he's saying 1263 and I
wonder if he got the wrong
number 1263 is parenting coordin
that is
yes they don't match any of he gave
us I don't know
yes hi hi Mr chairman um did we vote to
put the prior bill on consent
calendar okay can we back so what do I
we held this bill so we could add stuff
to it no the prior the first no not n no
not with this vote no we did not
574 185 no 574 574 the prior one that we
just did that I'm writing the report
for uh yeah thank you for that thank
you uh where it go in the voting mode uh
no we're not we are not in the voting
mode was a motion made what not on this
one no
no there was
not there was no Amendment on motion on
that
okay uh we did not suggest that Senate
Bill
574 goes on to consent would you like me
to reopen that exact session so we can
say that okay I reopen Senate Bill 574
exec session uh is there any objection
to that bill going on
consent hearing seeing none uh to
consent and now I close the exact
session on
574 yo what somebody oh thank you you're
welcome
you um while we are waiting for
that um I want to say a few things about
uh Thursday it is my
responsibility to get the official
speakers for the committee to the
clerk uh Susie's Little Helper a couple
of years ago tried to do it instead of
me and was roundly chewed out I am the
one that does it I'm the one that gets
yelled at uh this does not mean that you
can't sign up to speak on your
own I'm going to need everybody's
attention here
uh it does mean that the official
speaker and the official Giver of the pi
need to come from me and I've talked
with most of you but I want to make sure
this is 100% correct before I send it in
uh we have five bills coming up if you
look at the house calendar we've got 359
which raises the marriage age to 18
there is you will see a floor Amendment
1455 on page
39 um the floor Amendment moved by to be
moved by representative yella and
seconded by representative D Simon that
adds a simple statement saying unless
the person is
emancipated I'm just giving you what the
batting order is speaking against that
floor Amendment uh not for the committee
but as people will be representative
Petrino and giving the pi if one is
needed representative LC now
when that comes when that that we know
that there's people speaking against it
if you can sign up to speak against that
Amendment if you
wish once the amendment is decided one
way or the other representative LC will
speak about the bill either OTP or
otpa and representative patrino will
give the pi this is at their
request um honestly
I don't know how many people are
emancipated in this state in the course
of the year and wish to get married at
age 17 I think I could probably count
the number on one
finger but but still okay any questions
on the batting order on
359 who's going to speak for it if it is
amended you said it would be le and
patrino they will be speaking for it no
matter how I get to assign that and they
volun
appeared if the amendment is accepted
they will speak for the bill that is
correct that is what you told me correct
okay good and since she's been the
guiding force on this and she wishes to
do that you got
it all right um let's go down to
463 I'm not quite sure what 463
is but it came out of here uh
unanimously an amendment I liked failed
so it is simply
OTP and representative D Simon you had
told me you would speak on
463 unless it's quickly voice
voted that's for court appointed counsel
for
children yep yep if that is 463 it is
okay you said you'd do that and
representative Greg would do the pi on
that
now
um there may be a
motion to
recommit that
bill back to this
committee I told the speaker that what
we had discussed last week is our
business is done
today and I did not sends anyone wanting
to come back to a recommitted bill that
we like as it is is a perfect no but we
like it that's why we we voted
it if there is a motion to recommit and
I spoke to the chair yesterday and he
said there
is and if it comes back to us here it is
I told him I might have to get about
eight or nine seat fillers who probably
don't want come in for a 30- second
motion I will make
OTP and of course they'll vote with me
or and the vice chair because that's
what seat fillers do so the speaker is
attempting to quell any attempt for this
to be recommitted but I just want you to
know if it is a motion I will I have a
blistering floor speech ready that
probably should be toned down but I'm
not not feeling it right now and I will
do the
pi there may be instead a floor
Amendment which I have not seen and I
will also speak against that and do the
pi uh there's some stuff floating around
that you know after a while guys we've
talked it to death you haven't gotten
your way several times I'll be damned if
you're going to get your way now I will
fight you yes thank you Mr chairman um I
thought the reason for um Rec committal
the last time was to add the definition
of fictive kin which we did in the
amendment correct
yes fictive kin it can be argued it has
been argued that the word kin in statute
was broadened to include non-blood
relatives but that would be an inference
that that is the definition of fictive
many states have found it important
since the word fictive is used not to
infer it from something else but to
Define it specifically so yeah we found
one of the objections one of the reasons
some people wanted this recommitted is
for a definition effective and I will be
continuing to fight for that definition
which came from a multi-state group of
people and when you do a side by side of
that multi-state group of people people
with what other states have it's almost
the same yes representative Greg thank
you Mr chairman um so the definition of
kin was actually expanded in 2022 did we
know that yeah so that's already in
statute right I I think I said that oh
okay great sorry my brain say fictive it
said kin is expanded to include
non-blood
relatives okay
so you know you coming from a legal
family you and me they're trying to get
if the word included there what does it
mean can we infer it from that probably
reasonably but it does not H to State it
the the word kin means cousin and it's
like Irish uh Scotch uh should this be
challenged I'm going to suggest that you
come as an expert witness well my my
mother's mother was Kinsman got it and
that now once the bill is ready to vote
on the bill representative Raymond said
you would make the
speech yes sir thank you and I'll do the
pi I think uh so that is taking care of
that
573 uh about confidentiality of Youth
health care and so on that came out of
here unanimous and it says so in the
calendar uh representative long I asked
to uh give the speech if necessary it'll
probably be voice voted but you never
know we've got to be ready
representative D Simon was asked to give
the pi and said yes now one
more
417 and remember we had a committee
Amendment and the committee Amendment
took out a very what some of us felt was
a very broad statement like if the the
kiddo isn't happy
and with something that the kiddo want
and isn't getting isn't happy with the
parents etc etc and uh the reason I
wanted that taken out is there's a good
chunk of my caucus that probably would
not support this bill if that statement
were in there according to the emails
I'm getting notwithstanding what other
laws may or may not say they want this
out and that's what the amendment did
also it took out a blunt statement that
said if you're found not to be
cooperative with the investigators we
could hold this against you that's my
paraphrase um that's a little in your
face that's a little threatening now we
know that's going to be true anyway if
somebody's investigated and they're
playing games you know that's going to
be held it's just felt that um it's too
much so we took that out in the
amendment and then finally we added the
definition of fictive k I'm going to add
this to every bill I can until it gets
into
law um so that was the amendment and I
am happy if it's challenged to defend
the committee Amendment with the speech
and representative D
Simone said she would do the pi on
that um and then the bill becomes OTP
with that Amendment and um I'm doing
something I don't usually do I'm doing
much of the speaking uh I will give the
speech and representative patr you said
that you would do the
pi thank you so that takes care of
Thursday um be on your
toes now the next item on our business
before we get back to the Senate bill is
on uh retained
bills and as you know we've got two of
them uh the speaker's office says that
we may start work on that in
June you or whoever signs up to be on
the retained Bill sub committee work
group may start now I think some of you
already have you can find information
you can have a chitchat with uh the
prime sponsor you can talk in ones and
twos and threes you just cannot go over
50% of who the work group is going to be
when we officially start perhaps in June
that will be at the call of the
subcommittee chair and then that has to
be noticed in the calendar that there
will be a public work group on you have
to name the date the place just like one
of these meetings so we've got two in
hand and what I would like to do is I
would like to see who would like to be
on
which
um one of them is
1269 and I believe that
1269 was the question of uh
restraints and that was by I can never
get his name right I think there's a
letter missing
meu muu
okay yeah it's it's another one of your
Irish friends representative bigford
good guy great guy but can't
spell um so I will be happy to take the
names of people interested and then
um make my my decision accordingly who
would like to be on 1269 representative
patrino because I've also already
appointed him as the chair of it anyone
else representative Nelson
representative D Simon who else did I
say
representative
n anyone
else I'm not going to make the
appointment representative Raymond yep
okay thank
you uh let's just give it a few more
minutes I'm not going to make an
official appointment I want to see what
the vice chair wishes to do and then we
have uh
Senate Bill 15 House Bill 1590 relative
to training regarding child abuse and
neglect for licensed Physicians advanced
practice nurses and physician
assistants um you know 1269 was
co-sponsored by all Republicans which is
why I put a Democrat to chair it uh 1590
was sponsored by all Democrats which why
is why I'm going to name me to chair it
um
um I can ask my staff about this because
I have Physicians and nurse
practitioners there who would like to be
on training regarding child abuse and
neglect it's not going to take long one
or two sessions at most 1590 this is
retain
Bill s before I okay I won't finish
writing your name thank you Mr chairman
um my concern because I would like to
serve on on either one of them but but
this one probably a little bit more so
is I'm not going to be around until
August once session's done I'm out of
here so that's my concern is being able
to serve please forgive me for rampant
jealousy here where you going
fla going to basic well I won't say the
word but that's how I feel it's a little
hot down
there yeah got there to do so I can't
guarantee uh when this will be done this
may well be done in
June if it's in June I can you can well
let's put you down and try to get this
thing I think we can crank it out in a
couple of go rounds okay um I'm I'm
coming up with a team here on this is
restraints representative me
MC
gu is his build remember that one yes uh
would you like to be on that uh
this is the people volunteering so far
you would uh sure sure
okay now we're on 1590 which is training
child abuse and neglect for Physicians
aprns and physician assistants okay I
think that one's GNA so I've got uh me
and representative sidal and
representative long So for anybody else
want to be on that representative
Raymond my streak continues alive I have
not missed your hand raised this
calendar year
thank you very much that that motivates
me well you know it's just a different
neck position I had to learn over
Christmas anyone else
representative oh the one
whose letters are all pronounced that's
ton and the one whose letters are not
all pronounced which is
LEC it's funny that way I mean it's
yeah we really could get into some
trouble here asking ourselves
why anyone else on this
one okay so here's what I've got um in
1269 chair is Petrino uh Nelson D Simon
LC Raymond and long 1590 the chairman is
the chair with Representatives sidel
long Raymond LC and D Simone um
you're doing hazardous Duty on something
else at the moment
so okay good now do we have the amended
Amendment uh she sending up to
HCA HCS and uh when they get it they
don't okay so those are the only those
are the only housekeeping items that I
have and unless anybody else has no
business
or sure
if there's no other business we are in
recess but don't go far because if the
amendment is up on the fourth
floor if the amendment is running down
the corridor towards the fourth floor we
should have it in hand fairly
soon so uh if you you want to get up and
stretch and so do do we not have to do
anything at all with this amendment no
that amendment is now dead it has not
been presented
no it wasn't it was pointed at it was
not officially
presented some chairman Like to Move It
formally so it can be discussed I do it
the other way
um and that's why we imploy thumbs in
this committee a lot yeah that's
why yeah
yeah
e
e e
hey wasn't that
fun talking with different ones that we
don't always talk with yeah okay open
the uh renew or get going once again the
exec set
on Senate Bill 459 you have a copy of
the new Amendment which takes out
several
lines that
uh representative Greg also known as
Eagle Eye
found and take a quick look at it and
then this should get done real quick
oh
yeah oh by the way anybody who signed up
to be on the um work group
for child restraints in
schools um M MCG sponsor uh here is the
bill and I'm giving them to the care of
the chairman of that group so in case
you would like another copy there it is
good and did we have the same for the
other retained Bill
printouts we have printouts of
1269 which is going to a special
committee on that's uh studying it and
we have a second uh retained bill that
we're doing something with
1590 that was handed around too yes it's
right here oh well done just have to
mention its number and it appears oh
okay I got okay can I have one of those
oh okay which one 159 they're both the
same Pat so it really doesn't matter no
this is 1269 159 I have a 1269 I'll swap
you I only have 159 anybody need a 1269
what am I offered for 1269 where right
okay here we go
1269 uh this is for the work group on
that
one sorry that's
fine here we
go okay what we're actually doing is
looking at Amendment
d673 H which uh no it isn't it is not
that just seeing if you're paying
attention it is
H and this is now the
amendment and we have to discuss put
into play the amendment before we put
the bill into
action e
Mr chairman yes sir can I ask a question
Mr chairman how did you change the pitch
of your voice so
quickly it's I first heard Mr chairman
and I said yes and then somebody about
an OCT of higher responded so with the
first person who's uh in a sort of a a
Meto baso range
yes I think here's your chance you I I
think my my neighbor here was helping to
get your attention for me um did you
wave I did was I looking in that
direction you were when you want to try
it again sure yes representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman I have a question
about the amendment um and how it fits
in with the bill um and I just want to
make sure that I'm understanding we're
keeping the bulk of
459 and then this amendment tacks on to
the end after where it says
report I sure hope so okay because it
amends the
title and then if you look at line eight
amend the bill by replacing section
five with the following so everything
that is in one two 3 4 is still good to
go so does to follow up does that mean
that the committee is no longer going to
do the section five which is the report
by November 1st 2024
oh probably should be section
six it would seem so oh no because this
says it starts with Section six so one
would think that it replaces section six
and Beyond yeah they rumed it yeah the
numbers change in a new right thank you
so if it starts the new one starts with
Section six instead of of
five so
confusing anything else
Bud says replacing section five that
means section five goes which is what
she pointed
out and then it's starting at sections
new section six so we've lost five and
gained
a
six
there
yeah yeah you're amending the bill not
the old
Amendment
yeah I think I'm
yeah you replace
five just the numbering
off it just should just
that
second it should be an amend yes that's
my question do we lose the report
section of the original bill or do we
keep the report
section I don't know personally I think
at this time uh we do need to move
forward and not do all of this all over
again again uh however I do know from my
time at DHHS oversight committee which
is now four years uh some often if if
there is not anywhere a a requirement
that you send the following a report you
can ask for it and usually get it so I
mean I'm not sweating that as much as I
like
reports anything else are we ready we
ready to have somebody put this
amendment in
would you like to invite her to come
back in or should we give
her she could be she went there I
okay you're in the room anybody like to
move Amendment 1688 H
please I'll move the amendment the chair
recognizes repres representative Raymond
and her hand uh Republican to Second
it representative D
Simone any final
discussion seeing hearing none now would
the clerk please call the role on the
amendment
1688 and thank you to Vice chairman long
and Miss D for running this job so
quickly and Os on fourth floor when you
see them with the clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
La yes representative
ton yes representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative bogot yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel yes representative L yes
representative patrino will vote Yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes 13 to0
missing
isman
perz okay now the motion before us is SB
459 as amended by
H and the chairman will move the
bill and do I have a Democrat
second I saw the hand from
representative Greg
first any further
discussion would the clerk please call
the role Jim and Pearson yes Vice Jim
long yes representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson
yes representative McMahon yes
representative bogot yes representative
panck yes representative sidel yes
representative LC yes representative
Patrina will vote Yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes
motion carries 13 to zero with three
absence um Can this go on
consent so now
all right something to follow along okay
good this concludes
the exec session on cipil 14
459 curious you don't have to answer if
you don't want to but just the Curiosity
of the chair how many of you running
again all right that's Greg
Nelson what's her name I knew that was
wasid all along uh Raymond McMahon
good uh what's
this me that's
long that
is she's
moving okay and representative Bickford
so I don't know if anybody knows about
representative grman or Perez but it
will be good I'm
sorry rman is Gib and Perez said she's
not when I talked to her last week okay
Grossman is and Gibbons oh that's good
she said last week she wasn't I don't
she was not Perez I'm sorry
Perez okay and and panic wellow we'll
get the band back together again huh
yeah okay we will actually have a fall
session um some time to vote on the
recommendations of the two work groups
remember we don't vote uh other than
recommender I I that is to say wow this
is a great bill you ought to do
something with it or this sucks Canal
water don't touch it if you can help it
and that's basically our recommendations
and it gives people chance to uh file
bills if they want to so with that we're
done have a good summer see you on
Thursday
thank you sir for
coming it's not usually this chaotic
here but uh we have
fun oh really
oh okay we don't like to do that but
thank
you
e
e e